nina i want to start with you i'm sure
that kevin kwon who wrote
the book that this is based on had many
suitors
uh people wanting to make his book into
a movie
did you just basically say on the phone
or in a meeting hello
did you see the hunger games i'm the one
that brought those movies to the screen
so you need me how did you win him over
do you think
um no that wasn't really my approach
um but uh he did have mini suitors it
was definitely
a beauty contest and we met in person
um and we mostly just talked about uh
honestly just the huge mainstream appeal
of the movie
and that you know he and i were just
talking about this the other night which
is that on the one hand
everything that's been going on these
last few weeks is just
you know it's been a dreamy experience
and it's been a dreamy experience
throughout honestly we've had a as
you'll probably hear today just an
exceptionally
tight-knit group an incredible leader in
our director
and a just a level of devotion from the
people involved that's unusual
but um when
when we sat there at our big premiere we
were like this is what we pictured i
mean
it's it's beyond any expectation but it
is what we always
set out for and what we always imagine
what we always hope for
and so i think that meant a lot to him
which was that it wasn't a specialty
film
it wasn't uh oh this would be great for
the asian market it was like this is a
great
movie for mainstream audiences around
the world
period um and also that we've done a lot
of very faithful adaptations and that we
work closely with our authors
that they're what matters to them
matters to us and that was meaningful to
him
but i think there was just a very hard
to miss how
heartfelt our love of the material was
and how
ambitious our aspirations for the movie
and kind of on the same
note john my understanding is that if
you guys had wanted to
make even more money on the deal
you had other offers from streaming
services
but it was super important to you to go
with a traditional
movie studio so that this movie was seen
by audiences on the big screen
talking about that decision and how
important that was to you
um one i love netflix i am a faithful
subscriber
i watch it all the time i want to do
business with them
uh no they they're
you know the argument was they have this
massive subscriber
uh if you want eyeballs immediate
eyeballs all around the world no waiting
no depending on opening weekends or
reviews like that is the way to go it is
uh part of uh the future and um and then
the other way was something that
um kevin and i had talked a lot about of
of the goals of this movie which was
it's there is a message that is said
um in the cinema that it is uh worth
your time and your energy to leave your
home to
fight traffic and parking and stand in
line and pay for a ticket
and gather your friends and schedule put
in your calendar and then sit in a room
and then turn off the lights
let go of everything else and say tell
me a story and and
and just have an asian cast all asian
cast
uh in romantic roles and heroic roles
comedic roles
and to present it on a platter like that
it just i think it trickles to every
part
of pop culture when you do that and to
have a giant studio like warner brothers
to anoint that and spend 10 mil tens of
millions of dollars to
promote that uh sends messages that this
is good business and
i have to i don't know if we've said
this yet but i actually didn't have the
power
to say either thing it was nina and brad
and john that when the decision came
down they said
we defer to john and kevin that was
unheard of like that all their lawyers
i'm sure killed them after
um so i have to give that respect to
them and again i've never really
i don't think we've said that in the
interviews yet but um they they
empowered us to make that decision
constance how did you psych yourself up
for the really intense scenes that you
have with michelle yo i'm thinking about
mahjong i'm thinking about the scene on
the staircase what'd you do special for
those days
um i did a lot of preparation
and then i threw it away you know
because
you want to prepare and and have
everything that your character does and
says
you wanted to have like emotional
history like a resonance
uh so you know i built all of that but
then
when you're actually in the scene
i just throw it all away because um i
want
i want it to feel alive and not
pre-planned and i want to
work off of what michelle is is giving
me and
whatever might happen and and she was
just such a lovely person to act across
and um i think it brought out the best
in both of us
absolutely did henry your story
fascinates me your your background
is in television hosting so i like you a
lot um
but i could never do what you just did
in this film you blew me away thank you
did you know
you had this in you as has acting been
an aspiration for a while
or did someone have to kind of flip this
switch in your head that you could do
this
that guy right there um i was i was a
television host a presenter for a long
time doing
sort of investigatory kind of travel
shows for bbc discovery channel
and i get a random email um asking me to
introduce
uh john chu to me and to jump on skype
he has a project in mind
and of course i've heard of crazy rich
asians i live in singapore i've been
there for
for the past six years and it was the
biggest news um
and i was like oh my gosh maybe it's
like a small
sort of like small part like a cameo i
probably managed that
um and and he he worded his emails very
carefully from the beginning and he was
like oh you know i'm still
casting there's a couple of roll uh
rolls sort of hanging around so um you
know we'll send you the
we'll send you the sort of script and
well you read for me
um i get i get the sides and it's for
nick and suddenly i
i i panic and and i and it's it's either
that that sort of
flight or fight moment um and at that
point i realized that
it was such an important sort of moment
it was
either i throw myself 100 into this or
or i don't and in a run-up to that
moment
i've been the biggest fan of of of
cinema for
my entire life and not only sort of
enjoying the stories that been told but
the
the actual craft of how it's being told
so
you know it all it all sort of helped
but uh but i i definitely think it was
it was john's
initial face and uh face he's got a
beautiful face
um faith uh but also you know
pinatas and and nina's and brad's and
and
and everybody so um yeah i definitely
had the help and
and and working with with constance and
an amazing professional who who who gave
me so much to
to work with um i did my best
he gave me a lot of good stuff to work
with too because i had to be in love
with him
[Laughter]
it wasn't that hard ken i'm curious you
know you've built this amazing career
and most of the things that i see you in
you're surrounded by
non-asian actors so what is it like
to step on the set of a project like
this and look around that table
you know at the dinner table where we
meet you and to see
all of the other cast that you're
working with on this
yeah it was incredible because you know
i my
my point of view of kind of asians and
cinema and tv of
i think in the this this renaissance has
really started with fresh off the boat
just from my world view is that
because now it's on his fifth season and
you know i was fortunate enough to guest
star on fresh off the boat a couple
times and
um also because of fresh off the boat i
was fortunate enough to have my own show
of dr ken where it was based on like an
asian american family where we had
five asian american series regulars so i
think the movement
oh no thank you
[Applause]
and also not many people know this is
that
the producers are fresh off the boat um
they would put in calls to abc and
saying
you have to pick up ken's show and then
you have to give him the back nine you
have to give them the second season
and they they fought for me just as hard
and and so i was already
you know surrounded by a lot of love
behind the scenes
and when um when this happened
it was everything i had already had the
privilege to experience times 100.
it was you know we're in kuala lumpur
we're in singapore
and and to me this was like what an
amazing
cinematic foray you know of something
that
i think i think deep down inside every
asian american actor
wants to wants to be a part of something
like this so
it was nothing but pure joy my first
scene there yeah when you think back to
the making of this what was the one
set piece that was kind of the biggest
headache or production challenge for you
all
this is a it's actually it's a very um
competitive category
um um
i mean i i would have to say that
getting gardens by the bay we were
actually
very very fortunate this is where having
a company that has its
uh a home in singapore and has some pull
there
because we that gardens by the bay
location
which is for the big you know wedding
party i mean i
i there's so many locations that i
really love in the movie and there were
a lot of
challenges finding uh the location
for the the young family home was very
hard that does not exist in singapore
so uh that's in kuala lumpur that we
found that
um and that when we first found it it
was really run down and it had monkey
poop on the floor
it had no fluid it had no flowers it was
a it was like
it was collapsing on itself oh my god
um and nelson coates just brought it to
life and made it look so
beautiful and amazing but uh we were
down
to the wire on getting the location for
that and which of those
amazing you know electric trees i mean
there's no location like that that was
going to be a good substitute
if you didn't get it and so just
relentless
relentless politicking and pushing
and encouraging and nudging and john
would go back and forth and back and
forth to
from kl to singapore to fight for that
for
us um and but then also having to pull
it off because it would be open
all day long and then the second that
they would close for the evening we
would
run in make our movie and then make
ourselves scarce
for the next day and come back so that
was also a bit of a
a challenge and there was a family
affair because while we were in kl we
didn't have the location yet and
kevin uh quan visited visited
and he said he understood we were
stressing
and he said well you should ask janice
and
janice is one of the cast members janice
coe who plays one of the antes
said janice's husband is the head of
tourism
in singapore like now you tell me
so we called him and he
he said listen it's tricky it's their
fifth anniversary gardens by the bay is
a national
monument and they were they were doing a
light show
that was built years in production for
to project every night while we're
shooting
on all the trees and all the super trees
and
she janice ended up helping us through
and we got
right up to the prime minister's office
we didn't have to get to the prime
minister but very close
and even five days before they're like
yeah this is great but you can't have
any lights there because you're gonna
ruin our show
and they're like oh that's gonna be a
little tricky um but
it worked out thank you for making a
romantic comedy because we need more of
those
but congratulations on just a wonderful
film